hi this is fede master taught Andrews
again continuing on with our fundamental
checkmate lessons in the previous video
we learned how to checkmate with King in
a queen and also a queen and a rook and
two rooks and so now we're going to go
on with the king and rook checkmate and
we're going to conclude this video with
the two bishops checkmate the King and
the rook checkmate is has some similar
ideas to the queen and king king queen
checkmate however because the rook
doesn't move diagonal it takes a little
bit more work to accomplish it in this
video we're going to start with the end
first so look at the position in front
of you and the first thing I want you to
notice is that the two kings are lined
up directly in front of each other we
call this opposition in the chess
it creates basically a no-man's land
where neither King is able to legally go
to the three squares you see highlighted
in front of you see seven D seven and a
seven and so one King basically holds
the other one at bay in this position if
it was wide smooth because he would be
able to checkmate in one turn by playing
Ric f6 to f8 we call this the side
Swiper checkmate and we also talked
about this with the king and queen in
the previous video if you've seen that
one so you have to have the two kings
lined up opposite each other there is
only one exception to that when the King
finds himself in the corner then you can
have your King on b6 and it takes away a
7 and B 7 which are the only squares
that the black King could even have
access to so let's place a rook on D 1
there are two possible checks in this
position you could check you could go to
a1 and check him but then the King still
has access to the b8 squared so instead
to deliver mate here just like in the
last one the rook goes up to the a3 and
horizontally will sideswipe this King
and finish them off so let's do a couple
of examples here around different parts
of the board
all right this one is black to move
where would you move your rook in this
position to deliver checkmate
h1 and that way the work would be able
to sideswipe in from the H file
alright let's try this puzzle checkmate
in one move for white how can our rook
horizontality attack the black King here
rook h1 checkmate let's do one more over
here on this side of the board now
we hope you enjoyed this video demo from
chess comm subscribe today to finish
this video and get unlimited access to
our full video library your membership
also includes access to chess mentor the
most advanced interactive training tool
available anywhere you'll also get full
access to the opening Explorer tactics
trainer and much much more so sign up
today and get serious about improving
your game